if you need some help with your
penmanship try calling rapper offset
she's so cute i love her on tuesday
morning cardi b shared this sweet clip
of her husband helping their little girl
culture with her homework right here
finish it
their fingers just start
right there
thanks
good job the bodak yellow wrapper also
reveals that she forgot one of culture's
assignments so offset had to step in
before school to help their little one
finish
but it's not the first time offset has
lent culture a hand literally back in
february the musician sat down with his
baby girl to give her a manicure you'll
really be having her do whatever the
hell she wants my baby as for culture
seems she's working hard at school and
playing hard at home on monday night
cardi posted this sweet clip of her
daughter dancing to her favorite singer
jojo siwa on tv
and on sunday cardi used her time on
stage as the host of the 2021 american
music awards to make this simple holiday
request georgios could you please come
see my daughter and christmas yeah like
we said culture she's a big fan of the
dance mom star so my husband he was
trying to get georgia steve for my
daughter's birthday party but she is
booked and busy so let me tell you
something y'all rappers don't got
nothing on jojo siwa and jojo she
responded to the whop rapper's request a
little later on in the show cardi
you're gonna see what i can do and i'm
gonna try to make christmas happen i
promise putting it in my phone right now
i seriously though i cannot wait to meet
culture she is being raised by a
superstar
it's legend cardi b but jojo wasn't the
only artist culture was excited about
seeing at the amas here's what cardi
told et ahead of the big night i'm
excited to see bts i know my daughter
she she loves bts i like her to listen
to bts because you know they're like
more like friendly and they make her
dance and all that stuff so i know she's
gonna be excited to see them well when
eti caught up with the k-pop group on
the red carpet they sent a special
personalized message for culture what
message do you have for a little culture
let's do it again
you know what's up that's the culture
right there let's go
[Music]
you